[Aplausos]
hola hola buenos días cómo son todos
primero agradecer la invitación muchas
gracias a la gente esta plataforma
importante y segundo ustedes por darse
el tiempo de escuchar un poquito la
historia de una persona como ustedes
mi historia comenzó hace algunos años y
más o menos comienza así
quiero comenzar compartiendo con ustedes
lo importante que es para mí que sepan
mi nombre
tenía 20 años cuando comenzó todo
se imaginan tener 20 años
está lleno de sueños ser
un muchacho con ganas de comerse el
mundo amar algo como pocos saber qué es
lo que quería yo quería desde muy chico
ser músico lo ame con todas mis fuerzas
pero eso que amas con todas tus fuerzas
te arrebate a uno de los seres queridos
más importante de tu familia
a tu padre ya tu papá
bueno eso me pasó a mí
13 de mayo del 2007 domingo 13 de mayo
del 2007 un día de la madre
el cual muchos peruanos no van a olvidar
sobre todo yo
y no solo porque mi papá se fue ese día
sino porque la vida agarraba mis sueños
y mis ganas de comerme el mundo
me las arrancaba y me enfrentaba a la
realidad
una realidad dura una realidad la cual
estoy completamente seguro ningún hijo
está preparado
pero así es la vida había que darle una
prueba importantísima en mi vida solo
tenía 20 años la más importante para mí
era sacar a mi familia adelante
mi madre
super dolida
y una 97 años esas dos personas se
convirtieron en los motores de mi vida
esa era mi primera gran meta pero la
otra una responsabilidad también era
continuar con un legado el legado del
grupo néctar quien no había escuchado
del grupo conectar canciones como el
arbolito como pecadora que tenían su
propia historia
y un chico a esa edad iba a poder con
una responsabilidad tan grande
así comenzó todo así que empecé a
trabajar porque desde chico siempre he
sido una persona muy trabajadora muy
empeñosa
y enfrentarme a lo que la vida me ponía
la realidad empecé a trabajar al
comienzo había muchos que decían que eso
no iba a ser posible
muchas personas decían que no iba a
poder que el traje iba que era muy
grande y tal vez
tenían razón fácil no iba a ser pero
sólo dependía de mí de mostrarme a dónde
quería llegar
no sólo por mi sueño sino porque tenía
que hacer algo
y lo primordial era sacar adelante a mi
familia así que comencé empecé a
trabajar empezaron los comparativos no
no va por aquí no si empecé a hacerlo
cada vez mejor pasó un tiempo medio año
un año dos años tres años y conseguir
como lo que yo le llamo o a lo que le
llamé mi primera meta mi primera meta
cumplida mi primer logro fue convertirme
y ser aceptado como el nuevo cantante
del grupo nextel
y cuando me di cuenta de eso cuando
pasaba por la calle y a la gente me
decía oír
es decir que ante el arbolito ahora no
haber siempre utilizado la estrategia y
creo que muchos los que estamos sentados
aquí tenemos algo de eso yo tenía un
look completamente diferente no sólo era
por la moda también era para que la
gente no se confunda se tener el pelo
largo rayitos era parte de mi estrategia
yo comencé siendo el hijo de mi primera
gran meta fue ser aceptado como el
cantante del grupo néctar después de
años trabajando me gane el cariño de la
gente el cariño de la gente y todo
estaba bien aparentemente lo que se veía
estaba como en un piloto automático
empecé a
a tener cariño de la gente había mucho
trabajo
y había una estabilidad
pero sentí que eso no era suficiente
sentí que no estaba bien como miles y
miles de personas en provincias dándonos
sus cariños dándonos todo lo que tenían
y nosotros cuando hablan nosotros hablo
de gente que hace el género género que
amo con todas mis fuerzas que es la
cumbia
les retribuyan los espectáculos en
tarimas simples con cinco focos que se
movían
entonces yo dije
esto no está bien no les estamos
entregando a la gente lo que nos está
dando
porque y empecé a investigar empecé a
investigar empecé a siendo joven todavía
un poco más joven empecé a tener ganas
empecé a volver a soñar
paso el tiempo
y tuve una gran meta
otra meta saben cuál fue llevar a mi
género a mis raíces a lo que amaba con
todas mis fuerzas a otro nivel pero no
solamente para retribuir el cariño a la
gente sino para que en el mundo
conocieran
y aquí en nuestro país en el perú y que
los peruanos también podíamos hacer
cosas de calidad y no teníamos que
esperar que venga gente de fuera
solamente para ver
algo de nivel
así que decidí cuando empecé a sentir
esas emociones como las estoy sintiendo
en este momento porque recuerdo eso me
volví a sentir vivo volví a sentir que
mi vida tenía sentido volvía a sentir
que volvía a soñar que la vida me está
dando una nueva oportunidad y entonces
empecé a caminar soy de esas personas
que cree que la unión hacia la fuerza
soy esas personas que creen que los
peruanos juntos podemos salir adelante
lo hemos demostrado hace poco
pero en este caso
no fue como yo pensaba toqué muchas
puertas hablé con gente del círculo mío
porque eran más que un tema personal era
que el mundo nos conociera y escuchaba y
tuve respuestas como esas para qué
no estás loco déjalo así nomás y hay una
palabra que seguramente muchos han
escuchado en diferentes rubros así nomás
el famoso así nomás
yo no estaba dispuesto a vivir en él así
nomás
y solo me tenía me
y a mis sueños nuevamente había me había
reencontrado con eso así que había que
tomar una decisión y empecé a hacer las
cosas porque soñar es bonito pero
hacerlas es mejor aún entonces empecé
empecé a investigar me busqué y empecé a
buscar contactos y contacté con
productores porque sabía que había gente
que podía hacerlo aquí para esto el tema
de los tablados y de los focos no
solamente eran
entregarle a la gente poca calidad sino
también era que nos vieran de una manera
diferente poco formales poco serios y no
era así habíamos personas en el rubro
que queríamos hacer cosas diferentes
pero nadie se atrevía
y yo no voy a esperar que alguien se
atreva para ver lo que yo estaba viendo
y de allí contacte búsqueda unos
productores después de muchas reuniones
después de muchos intentos logré tener
opción a una cita con unos productores
importantes de aquí
nos llegaba la cita al comienzo no
llegaba nos lleva hasta que me aceptaron
nunca había esperado tanto un asiste en
mi vida de algunos chicos que se ríen
bueno si ni siquiera para una chica la
verdad que si no entonces eso me ha
marcado por eso lo tenía que tocar aquí
hasta que es la ansiada cita llegó la
ansiedad llegó me recibieron muy puntual
yo como ahora llegué fui y estaba con
ganas era más chico tenía veintitantos
años y tenía
lo que después aquí en mi cabeza tenía
la idea clarísima cómo sería esto
les voy a compartir cómo me recibieron
me acerque a la oficina
intenté presentarme estaba ahí esperando
llegaron el productor me dijo hola cómo
estás
hola le digo qué gusto intentar
presentar me dijo si hiciste conozco tú
eres el que canta cumbia no
y yo no le dije con cariño no le dije no
no
no podía decirle eso
pero
entendía por qué porque el gesto de
cumbia
claro así nos veían como poco serios
como gente que solo
trabajar en él así nomás
yo había pedido unos requerimientos le
había comentado qué es lo que quería lo
que quería era llevar a mi género a otro
nivel y para esto se requería una
inversión grande lógicamente sabía sabía
y fue con una base entonces me respondió
muy sincero él me dijo no tengo mucho
tiempo estos son los requerimientos
joven que usted ha pedido
y me entregó una hoja agarré la hoja
emocionado al comienzo y después empecé
a verla
entenderán que estoy recordando esa hoja
no
señores nunca había visto tantos ceros
en mi vida
yo sabía que hacer algo de otro nivel y
va a costar algo
y había ido con una base base de mis
ahorros años de trabajo pero eso no era
una base eso eran dos torres gemelas o
sea me estaban ponía yo sabía que sabe
querían que yo lleve mi género a otro
nivel pero era un número impagable para
mí en ese momento y estoy seguro que
para muchos en este momento
que me doy cuenta una vez más que la
vida
me vuelve a enfrentar ante la realidad
mis sueños mis ganas de querer hacer las
cosas
frente al
a la realidad era una cifra impagable
empecé a ponerme nervioso me dijeron
entiendes no sabía términos que no
entendían yo sí sí sí claro
e improvisó una llamada porque los
nervios no son buenos para nada y menos
en una negociación
imprevisión a llamada elegí menos unos
minutos tengo que hacer una llamada y me
dijo me miró como que se asustó y sí
si esta es la verdad bueno estás estado
y me fui
recuerdo que
si me puse nervioso empecé a sudar y
estaba sudando
y mire está en el baño y me mira al
espejo
me miré al espejo y empezaron a pasar
miles y miles de cosas por mi cabeza
porque estaban mis sueños pero también
estaban mis responsabilidades mi familia
a continuar con eso arriesgar las no o
quedarme en el así nomás
pasaron muchas cosas por mi cabeza y
dije la vida me enfrenta una vez más a
la realidad pero esta vez lo hacía de
una manera diferente
no me ponía al frente a solucionar algo
oa enfrentarme la y me daba a decidir
esta vez yo tenía la opción de decidir
ese momento sólo dependía de mí
y recordé todas las cosas fuertes que
habían pasado por mi vida
y también cuántas puertas se me habían
cerrado y sabía que era una oportunidad
grande difícil salir
me decidí tomé coraje
y hablé con él le hablé con la misma
sinceridad que él me habló y me dijo
todo bien si le dije todo bien me dijo
te veo
como me habrá visto anoche
todo bien y si le digo todo bien y sabes
que le digo te agradezco el tiempo y lo
que quiero hacer
a hablarte con la misma sinceridad que
tú me hablaste
no tengo la plata
este es un número muy alto no tengo en
la plata
me dio un gesto
como ya sabía que eso iba a pasar no
eres el primero que viene hacer cosas a
querer hacerlas
lo que no imagino fue lo que le dije
después
no tengo la plata
pero si esto es lo que hay que hacer
para llevar mi género
el género de nuestro país a otro nivel
la voy a conseguir
y jugué el todo por el todo
me jugué mi casa me jugué mis ahorros
porque entendí que si yo no lo hacía
nadie más lo iba a hacer por mí
y si está la opción de que no hubiese
salido como yo pensé
que hubiese sido lo peor
y volverlo a hacer volverlo a intentar
porque todo lo que tenía aquí era llevar
a mi música que en el mundo conocieran
que en mi país se hacían cosas de verdad
y el resto es historia conocida cambia
las giras nacionales por giras
internacionales tuve el placer de
compartir escenarios en otros países con
artistas como carlos vives romeo santos
silvestre dangond hace propuestas que
nunca imaginé en mi vida y lo más
importante dejar la huella de nuestro
país en cada rinconcito de estos lugares
y así como en algún momento nuestra
comunidad es reconocida la música
también empezó a hacerlo
el 20 de septiembre del 2014 en uno de
los locales más emblemáticos de la
cumbia peruana el huaralino se realizó
el primer concierto nunca antes visto en
la historia de la música popular peruana
la cumbia aquí por primera vez la gente
del género veía un espectáculo de
calidad como cualquiera de otro nivel
por fin los peruanos teníamos algo
propio
y si estoy aquí parado
es por eso
comencé siendo el hijo de
la vida me dio la oportunidad de decidir
arriesgue y hoy estoy aquí teniendo mi
propio nombre apareciendo en un afiche y
siendo presentado con una marca propia
saben por qué porque no sólo soñé
porque no solo tuve una idea sino porque
me decidí a hacerlo porque soy un
hacedor y estoy completamente seguro de
muchos de los que están aquí esta mañana
lo son también
la única oportunidad que tenemos para
cumplir
lo que nos proponemos dice nosotros
mismos
lo peor que puede pasar es que lo
vuelvas a intentar
quién está parado aquí es un hacedor un
peruano que no va a parar de hacer cosas
hasta que el mundo conozca sus raíces su
música su cumbia peruana muchas gracias
[Aplausos]